هذا موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قال مصدر رسمي
تركي للجزيره انه تم ابلاغه الجانب الروسي
بعدم قبول تركيا الانتشار الشكلي لقوات
النظام السوري في مناطق ما تعرف بقوه
سوريا الديمقراطيه واوضح المصدر انه تم
اعداد كافه تجهيزات العسكريه واللوجستيه
اللازمه لتنفيذ العمليه العسكريه شمال
سوريا وقال ان العمليه لن تهدد القوات
الامريكيه والروسيه
تواصل اتصالاتها مع الاتراك بشان تصعيدي
في شمال سوريا كما قال انا بلاده خلص
الدورياتها شمالي سوريا
اعرب المبعوث الاممي الخاص الى سوريا
نعم
في شمال سوريا حضر من ان تصاعد القتال قد
يعرض الاستقرار الاقليميه للخطر
بثمانيه مجموعات قتاليه في بلغاريا والمجر
وبولندا والاتفيا واستونيه ورومانيا
وليتوانيا
افراد هذه المجموعات من جنسيات المختلفه
وهم مستعدون للقتال وان وجودهم يوضح ان
الهجوم على حريف واحد هو هجوم على الجميع
كما قال الامين العام
اعضاء الحلف يبحثون تسليما اوكرانيا
منظومه الدفاع بتريوت المضاده للصواريخ
اوكرانيا بانظمه باتريوت فاستصبح تلك
الانظمه هدفا مشروع بلاده في حين قال
البنت
الراهن لارسال بطاريات باتريوت الى
اوكرانيا
نقلت وكاله بلومبرجان دبلوماسيين قولهم ان
المحادثات بين الاطراف الاوروبيه بشان
تحديد سقف لاسعار النفط الروسي لا تزال
عالقه حول ذلك قبل اسبوع من حضر اوروبا
واردات الخامر الروسيه
هكذا
في رساله لمنتدى اعمال الطاقه الروسيه
الصينيه الرابعه ان الصين مستعد للعمل مع
روسيا من اجل دعم امن الطاقه في العالم
كما جدد نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه
اليكساندر نوفاك رفض بلاده لتحديد سقف
لاسعار النفط الروسيه مشيرا الى ان القيود
الغربيه في هذا الشان يمكننا ان تؤدي الى
نقص في موارد الطاقه في العالم
شدد الحزب الشيوعي الصيني في بيان الله
على ضروره قمع ما سماها الاعمال غير
القانونيه والاجراميه التي تخل بالنظام
الاجتماعيه مع المحافظه بجديه على
الاستقرار الاجتماعيه الشام
كما افادت مراسله الجزيره بان الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه للمطالبه برفع الاغلاقات في مختلف
المدن الصينيه توقفت تعزيزات الامنيه
مشدده في العاصمه وفي شنغهاي
اعلنتا شرطه الباكستانيه مقتل ثلاثه من
رجال الشرطه واصابه اكثر من 20 في هجوم
الانتحاريه بمدينه كويتيه جنوب غربي
البلاد وقالت الشرطه ان الهجوم استهدف
دوري للشرطه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]